[Musique]
et
bien je suis avec véronique simple un
bonjour bonjour patrick va bien très
bien alors on est sur le site du du golf
national ça tombe bien parce que c'est
un site olympique et on va parler
évidemment avec vous de votre
association qui s'appelle sos gazelle et
d'une opération formidable qui concerne
350 jeunes d'île de france que vous
lancer et qui s'appelle ornaient les
panneaux hier paris 2024 inverse par et
2024 cd jose en afrique évidemment tout
à fait ouais alors quand même faire
parce que vous avez aussi une balle
roland garros et c'est pas pour rien
c'est parce que c'est pas juste pour
faire joli
parce qu'on va raconter un peu de
l'histoire de sos gaz aide est cédé à
roland garros signer à roland garros en
fait moi j'étais joueuse de tennis je
démarrais ma carrière professionnelle
chez nike en tant que directrice
marketing et je savais que les tournois
étaient en concurrence les tournois du
grand chelem et je voyais les sportifs
de haut niveau se mettre au golf ce soit
dans le foot le rugby et j'observais que
de nombreux joueurs de roland garros
aller jouer sur les golfs à côté à la
boulie je vends le directeur de roland
garros et je lui dis voilà un super
service apporté aux joueurs une
compétition amicale de golf avec des
pros
ils me contactent qu'elle très peu de
temps après il a trouvé l'idée géniale
et il me dit si tu as l'audace de mettre
ça en place je te donne le label roland
garros rgab aînés le tiebreak du jeu de
mots pour expliquer parce que dit break
10 c'est le t1 du golfe à la boutique et
a évidemment c'est la référence à tie
break c'est ce disent c'est ce mariage
au fond des joueurs de tennis avec le
golf on sait ça le mariage de sa le
multisports en fait cessé voilà je
trouvais que les sportifs étaient un
petit peu chacun de leur côté et il ya
une grande admiration de différentes
disciplines les uns envers les autres et
marié tous ces sportifs ensemble sur une
belle journée c'était ça le au départ
il ya évidemment oui d'autres sportifs
qui vont arriver un dans cette
compétition petit break et puis
à cette compétition d'abord ça fait
évidemment c'est un événement formidable
peau pour ceux qui y participent mais
c'est aussi une manière de récolter un
peu des fonds c'est ça en fait c'est
devenu très vite une journée totalement
caritatives au départ on était des
associations de jeunes
et c'est ici au golf national que boris
diaw a dit mais véronique et très
fédératrice plutôt qu'on a chacun notre
asso selva créé son association et on va
tous est vert et or autour d'elle et on
a créé sos gazelle et depuis le tiebreak
est totalement caritatif c'est à dire
que tous les gens viennent bénévolement
ont fait des dons tout au long de la
journée et il ya les fameux enchères et
il ya des ventes aux enchères de alors
de 2,2 de maillot collector de 20,2 de
raquettes de tennis collector etc
travail et il ya des enchères des
entreprises aussi que tu viennes qui est
qui et qui très gentiment enfin monde
des enchères ça ça vous a rapporté par
exemple la dernière de 17000 euros et
pour une sur une année difficile d'après
coheed et en fait c'était toute l'année
les sportifs de haut niveau moi je suis
à la course sur les terrains de match et
ces gens dit n'oubliez pas parce que
c'est une chance quand même
extraordinaire ce sont des maillots
authentifié deux joueurs c'est enseigner
et il faut dire quelque chose qui est un
avantage fiscal en france c'est qu'il ya
une récupération de 66% voilà donc on
peut être content pour son road
exactement et les entreprises lee
l'utile à l'agréable
ils sont ravis d'inviter des clients à
participer avec des grands champions
quand même tu as vu l'ambiance du
tiebreak j'y étais
et très conviviale de golf r sens
c'était une golf r semble parker sent
qu'il ya aussi un très très beau
signifie et en parallèle de la compet de
gaulle comme tu l'as vu on invite
toujours des jeunes il ya toujours une
centaine de jeunes encadrés par des
champions voilà alors c'est ça sos gaz
et là c'est les jeunes les jeunes et les
valeurs du sport tout à 10 ans très
importante pour eux c'est ça nous le
thème central c'est l'éducation
par la santé et le sport le sport
véhicule des très belles valeurs je dis
toujours que le sport est rassembleur au
delà des différences on est aussi bien
en afrique au népal dans différents pays
et en france bien sûr et il y ait des
grands sportifs ils viennent de
l'encadrer il a fait encore
et puis on a aussi des nutritionnistes
on a décliné on a des médecins du sport
des éducateurs parce que le programme
est vraiment complet notamment celui ci
qui a démarré et qui est parti pour
trois ans un peu oui oui oui oui il vint
voilà donc sur des lieux d'ile-de-france
avec des partenaires les comme ici le
golf national comme comme le golf de
saint quentin saint quentin le 14
octobre comme le centre beau boxing
d'achères qui d'ailleurs j'ai appris je
ne savais pas tony yoka ont fait partie
le csc loi la celle saint cloud avec les
jeunes footballeurs qui vont inviter
d'autres jeunes de l'association et on
invite à chaque fois des écoles et
essayer de trouver des jeunes qui ont et
du mérite qui ont envie de s'en sortir
mais pour qui lé quotidien n'est pas
obligatoirement faciles alors comment
comment justement vous vous repérer ces
jeunes comme on voulait sélectionné
comment comment ça se passe alors c'est
de longue haleine on essaie de faire
très attention d'être vigilants tous les
partenaires les clubs de sport les
écoles les centres de kiné chacun
sélectionne une vingtaine d'enfants
parce qu'ils les connaissent depuis
nombreuses années les a observés et
qu'ils estiment qu' il le mérite parce
que ils n'ont pas obligatoirement des
conditions favorables de vie et surtout
ils ont envie de s'en sortir
il montre des qualités parce que je
pense que dans la vie ce qui gagne celle
échange de bons procédés nous on est là
en soutien mais il faut que ces enfants
10 et une volonté aussi un voilà voilà
une volonté de rendre ça les amène à
voir cette volonté de se battre de ces
des valeurs si vous affichez de varia
tous acquis qui jouait les six
disciplines c'est fort oui le collectif
mais beau gosse il a vu vous jouez en
équipe moi j'ai fait aussi du marathon à
côté du tennis ça reste le sport reste
collectif même sur un sport individuel
talent copains qui te quitte aid kit
soutien etc c'est vrai que les valeurs
de l'olympisme puisque c'est vers paris
devenue 24 l'opération basso sur des
valeurs qui sont très importantes pour
pour des enfants justement pour leur
donner une les structures et si je me
suis pas dit ça et puis tôt
tu remarqueras aussi qu' il ya des
sports grâce aux jeux olympiques qui
sont mises en lumière avec ses jeux trop
peu parce que c'est tous les quatre ans
et qui mériterait beaucoup plus et moi
je depuis temps par exemple je pense pas
au groupe est agacé au skeleton j'ai
découvert le skeleton grâce à un athlète
que le skeleton c'est comme tu pousses
et c'est
c'est le sait le bobsleigh à l'envers
c'est à dire que tu vas de tête de la
première c'est un truc de dingue très
rapide et grégory saint genies qui
maintenant fait partie de la fédé nous a
fait découvrir ça
regardez sa visibilité sur internet et
skeleton qui il est il est au coeur de
la préparation des jo mais au sein de
l'atleti s'il ya beaucoup de sport qui
mériterait plus nous tant sur le plan
médiatique sur le plan des moyens parce
que moi qu'il faut revenir encore à la
jeunesse ce qui m'a fait faire le
tiebreak c'est le champion d'europe de
triathlon qui me dit verrou j'en peux
plus m'entraîner j'ai pas un centime je
fais des crises et salades et des grands
sportifs ya des sports où ils sont
délaissés ou en panachant absolument
j'ai donc c'est vraiment lui qui m'a
donné cette idée de dire ça va être la
rencontre de deux mondes alors il ya des
footballeurs des rugbymans des tennis
mag il ya très bien leur vie et qui sont
à égalité et les rencontres se font
également avec le monde économique et ça
passe des choses et des histoires les
gens faux arrive à trouver des à l'issue
de taille des points communs voila voila
émettront des projets en commun alors
qu'ils viennent tous ce n'est pas pour
les enfants et ça c'est sincère on le
voit tout à ce moment on regarde sur les
images ils sont attaqués et parce que
souvent aussi des sportifs qui se
retrouvent dans ces enfants et parfois
ils viennent de deux pas forcément de
milieux très favorisés tous donc il
retrouve un peu leur histoire travers
ses enfants ils ont envie de leur donner
leur chance à leur tour quoi et c'est
presque ce que tu dis parce que j'ai
remarqué aussi une chose dans les
sportifs de haut niveau ils ont tous
cédé rage de vaincre et moitié chez du
coaching mental en parallèle
jeu comme je discute avec eux de manière
un peu confidentiel je lui dirai pas une
revanche sur la vie mais il ya on a tous
des fractures enfants des problèmes dans
les familles et on sent qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose qui les a boostés au
lieu de les détruire au contraire ça
leur a donné la la gagne ils
rebondissent parce qu'en fait on a tous
des échecs les sportifs de haut niveau
ça peut être des moments très durs et
paris 2024 ces quatre ans de préparation
et parfois ça se joue sur une seconde
sûr à 100 m sans bien sûr parfois
tristement une blessure juste avant
favier il peut y avoir des drames aussi
comme ça qu'on s'est réjoui jean presque
badin de 4 ans ou 5 ans ou disons
d'entraînement corps et qui mieux que
ces champions qui ont vécu ça pour
encadrer les enfants et leur apporter
des tas de conseil en prévention que ce
soit en prévention santé en sport et ses
enfants la chance de faire du multi
sports dire qu'un petit footballeur va
s'essayer au goal un tennisman va
s'essayer au rugby découvrir aussi ouais
et alors on le disait la salle concert
de l'opération vers paris 2024 350
enfants de l'est de l'île de france
qu'est ce qui va ce alors concrètement
qu'est-ce qui comment ça se passe pour
eux elle rencontrer des sportifs c'est
ça c'est ça donc on identifie des
journées alors il ya des après-midis
souvent les mercredis après midi sur des
lieux fixes et à part ça il y aura une
dizaine de journées entières type un
petit break ou des sportifs de haut
niveau des éducateurs des
nutritionnistes des professionnels de
santé vont se mettre complètement à leur
service et vont leur faire une journée
entière ils auront un carnet de bord
suivi avec leur programme scolaire a
suivi alimentaire le kiné va leur faire
également des exercices importants comme
le suivi alimentaire c'est vrai que
donner des règles pour l'alimentation
c'est aussi important c'est aussi des
choses qu'il faut leur répondre mais en
fait je sais pas si tu as vu au tiebreak
y avait des plateaux de fruits 6 mai les
enfants petit moi j'étais en afrique et
je leur disais ils étaient tous avec
leur coca alors qu'ils ont des jus
naturel extraordinaire et je leur dis
est ce que vous savez que le pape et il
paye 15 euros pour boire un jus naturel
de mangues qui maillent coq à la
poubelle parce que tu leur dis moi çà et
là on voyait tous ces gamins poser leurs
cadettes pour aller voir et le la
rencontre suivante il était avec leur
jus naturel très fier je fais comme pape
et donc c'est l'exemple de maisons et
leur expliquer parce que les canettes y
en a partout si on leur explique que
avec un fruit avec des jus naturels ils
vont avoir une énergie démultiplier et
qui vont devenir champion grâce à ça
parce qu'il ya pas de miracle si tu es
qu'est ce qui fait la différence
également talent égal l'hygiène de vie
général la technique la tactique etc
c'est petit il y en a beaucoup qui l'ont
pris mais celui qui va des noté il aura
une hygiène de vie il aura un équilibre
général et donc toutes ces notions sait
on veut leur donner des petits parce que
nous on n'a pas eu ça et ses champions
la con 40 ans ou n'ont pas eu sa reprise
ça c'est vrai qu'il ya un changement
aussi dans l'éducation des sportifs qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on prend contre 8
août toute une série de secteurs
autrefois les gens ils arrivent et on
s'échauffait peu voilà désormais c'est
vrai que j'avais c'était comme contenu
de jouer au tennis là on avait eu sur le
coup ont joué tout de suite c'est
aujourd'hui avocat il ya beaucoup de
procédures concours qui ont changé et
c'est bien de les apprendre très jeune
aux enfants la santé donc c'est aussi
très important très important alors
santé prévention santé donc avec des
kinés des prof de yoga parce que voilà
quelques jeux la respiration moi comment
je m'en suis rendu compte par hasard je
coache au niveau mental de petits jeunes
du psg qui m'expliquait que sur les
accélérations il avait du mal à
récupérer je leur fais découvrir la
respiration ventrale et là la séance
suivante ils me disent mais c'est génial
on a gagné en récupération donc toutes
ces notions qui sont finalement du bon
sens mais que la vie nous n'oublie pas
le savoir voilà donc tous ses éducateurs
vont être là pour leur rappeler pour
leur faire vivre en direct parce que y'a
rien qu à la prof de yoga elle les a
allongé elle aura à montrer un petit peu
et ils ont dit c'est extraordinaire donc
c'est sur le terrain sur le terrain mais
avec un suivi aussi des bilans tous les
trois mois ce qu'on va passer la tv
un vrai suivi il ya suivi et les enfants
auront seront parrainés ou marrainée par
quelqu'un de l'encadrement est ce que
y'a encore des blast je décide des
associations ou des jeunes veulent
veulent vous contacter ils peuvent aller
sur le site de sos gazelle acte avant
c'est ce que j'allais proposé il ya
encore des places et si on peut aider
des jeunes méritants etc on étudiera
avec avec beaucoup d'attention leur
candidature parce que si on peut voit là
et des quelques jeunes donc n'hésitez
pas à nous contacter et on sera ravi de
d'étudier les demandes au contraire et
d'élargir le spectre on va faire au
mieux maximum c'est formidable mais
voilà elle est formidable
chaplin elle souhaite gazelles se sont
de l'association et l'opération c'est
vers paris 2024 beaucoup fait avec
plaisir
[Musique]